I tell you almost ran over somebody on a
bicycle today on a [ __ ] purpose
oh so [ __ ] annoying because they
write they write out in the [ __ ] road
now in the middle of the road right out
in the road then they feel because they
painted a bicycle on the street that
they now can do this which they can and
it gets annoying did you hear me well
I'm in a hybrid we can hear me it's 40
miles an hour move over this guy he had
this big [ __ ] ass
he was a fat dude he was wearing like
Tour de France shorter biker shorts and
they were white so this big white ass
was in front of me through the
temptation but you know what an ass call
when you just get caught partyís end up
going I was just gonna guess inch up on
his back tire just watch him just don't
kill him but [ __ ] him up a little bit
just slide I had a lady do that to me as
I was coming down Virgil and she was
right in the middle and then she would
stop we'd come to a stop line and she'd
just get right in there and block me she
[ __ ] I wanted her to pull to the side
and I wanted to be able to take the pole
position and then advance faster but she
was purposely just staying right in the
middle and I gave her a nice little a
little honk just like hey Pete [ __ ]
people if you will and she just turns
her a douche peep yeah I'm here not kind
of a lady and she she just turned to me
and with a big she got it all the time
so just turn me in her way like kill me
with kindness and she has waved at me
and that made me angry and then I I I
did rev past her but the the shitty
thing about that is that you do get
stuck in traffic and then eventually I
look up and she was three blocks ahead
MA so ultimately because she can cheat
she can be a car when she wants to but
then she can just cut she's on the
sidewalk at some point and I oh you know
they that they don't obey the rules of
the road whatsoever but yes but what the
worst part is is if you hit one hit one
like they're not even human
if you hear one of these [ __ ] people
you're on a % liable this despite the
fact the way they're riding around yeah
oh we said something a couple of crazy
old people right now like the two old
men in the new talked about breakfast
commercials a waffle do the level
low-level waffle taco the level of road
rage that I have I'm actually like I
talk about la like it's alive that's how
angry I get like I saw I was Cruz and
everything was going great then there
was just that one little Construction
sign and everything just ground down to
a halt so I know I'm gonna cut this way
and go up and go around and blah blah
and I made the right and I make the the
made the left then I make the right and
as I'm driving up it's a [ __ ] dead
end so I can't do it I started screaming
how does it know it's like no it's like
no it knows what you're trying to do and
it's like it's gonna work it's gonna
work and go [ __ ] yourself I was worth it
to ended up taking me longer